executive has discussed and we have
concluded that we must put the following
measures
in place first of all maintenance of
current household restrictions this
means a continuation
of the restriction on meeting indoors
and a limit on the number who can meet
in a garden there are existing
exemptions for child care and
maintenance
and other matters which will stay in
place
however as close contact economy is
proposed for closure
it would be consistent with that to
prohibit the provision of those service
for example hairdressing
in a domestic setting bubbling is to be
limited to a maximum of 10 people from
two households no overnight stays in a
private home
unless in a bubble work from home
unless unable to do so in guidance we
will advise universities and further
education to deliver distance learning
to the maximum extent possible
with only essential face-to-face
learning where that is a necessary and
unavoidable part of the course
closure of the hospitality sector apart
from deliveries and take away for food
with the existing closing time of 11
o'clock remaining
other takeaway premises will be then
brought into line with hospitality
with a closing time of 11 pm
retail will stay open however there will
be urgent engagement with the sector to
ensure that retail is doing everything
it can to help suppress the virus
closure of close contact services apart
from those meeting essential health
needs
which will be defined in the regulations
to ensure continuation of essential
health interventions and therapeutics
this will not include complementary
treatments
no end indoor sport of any kind or
organized contact sport involving
household mixing
other than at elite level no mass events
involving more than 15 people
except for allowed outdoor sporting
events where the
relevant number for that will continue
to apply
gyms may remain open but for individual
training only with local enforcement in
place
places of worship are to remain open
with a mandatory requirement to wear
face coverings when entering and exiting
and this will not apply to parties to a
marriage or civil partnership
wedding ceremonies and civil
partnerships to be limited to 25 people
with no receptions this will be
implemented on monday the 19th of
october
venues providing the post-ceremony or
partnership celebration
may remain open for this purpose this
weekend but may not provide
other services for people who are not
part of the wedding
or partnership and this will be limited
to 25
funerals and committals to be limited to
25 people with no pre
or post funeral gathering in guidance
no unnecessary travel will be advised
off licenses and supermarkets will not
be permitted to sell alcohol
after 8 pm and we believe the above
restrictions
should apply for 4 weeks and the
continuation or amendment of any element
would require executive approval
in education the half-term holiday break
will be extended from the 19th to the
30th of october
with schools reopening again on monday
the 2nd of november
to permit this the department of
education will allocate schools
too of the optional days and the
remainder of additional time
through exceptional closure days as
across other jurisdictions the issue of
schools along with other considerations
will be kept under continuous review
by the executive in the weeks and months
ahead
we fully appreciate that this will be a
difficult and worrying news
for a lot of people the executive has
taken this decision because it is
necessary
and we discuss the impacts in great
detail
and we do not take this step lightly we
want these measures to have two
impacts firstly on the covert
transmission rates which must be turned
down now or we will be in a very
difficult place
very soon indeed and secondly we believe
it marks a point where everyone
each and every one of us can take stock
and go back to the social distancing
messaging
that is vitally important we will of
course be engaging with sectors and
working on supports
as a matter of priority we are asking
all children and young people and their
parents to help us in a very particular
way
during the next few weeks please make
sure that your children and young people
follow the social distancing
arrangements during this time
limit socializing as much as possible
and use the time in as positive a way as
you can
we will need to exit these arrangements
most carefully
they will be put in place during friday
of this week and will be there for four
weeks any extension or amendment to them
will require a decision
of the executive we must reach a
different place on both the numbers
and on getting back to the basics of
social distancing and i know that
everyone
in this chamber will want to work with
us on that
mr speaker small acts can have a large
and important contribution to managing
covet 19.
so wash your hands practice social
distancing
wear face coverings small acts
but vitally important thank you mr
speaker